et un commandement militaire de l'espace
l'espace est devenu complètement clé en
termes à la fois militaire et en termes
économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour l
assister à une guerre dans l'espace oui
la guerre est possible il ya de
multiples façons d'amener de rendre
inopérant effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
que 220 morts c'est le nouveau bilan des
inondations dévastatrices qui ont touché
la belgique et l'allemagne
un bilan qui pourrait s'alourdir de
nombreuses personnes sont portées
disparues l'ouest
de l'allemagne est particulièrement
touché par ces crues avec au moins 103
morts ont fait le point dès le début de
cette édition mise en examen d'eric
dupond-moretti une première pour un
ministre de la justice en fonction il
est soupçonné de conflits d'intérêts
une mise en examen après six heures
d'interrogatoire par la commission
d'instruction de la cour de justice de
la république
[Musique]
l'indonésie nouvel épicentre de la
circulation du virus en asie plus de
cinquante six mille nouveaux cas hier
plus de mille décès en 24 heures les
hôpitaux sont débordés par l'afflux de
malades et la propagation du variant
delta les habitants des îles de bali et
de java / qu'on finisse
[Musique]
d
excellent vendredi à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur rt france pour une
nouvelle demi heure d'information au
moins 103 morts en allemagne plus de 20
en belgique les pays bas le luxembourg
ou encore la suisse sont aussi touchées
par les pluies diluviennes qui se sont
abattues ces derniers jours l'europe est
sous le choc de ces inondations
dévastatrices le bilan des victimes
pourrait encore s'alourdir car de
nombreuses personnes sont toujours
portées disparues le point avec les gore
douce et et florian lambert
des images qui témoignent de la violence
des intempéries ces derniers jours
c'est une partie du vieux continent qui
subit de plein fouet ce drame
conséquence d'une météo déchaînée
l'allemagne nation la plus endeuillée
déplore déjà une centaine de victimes et
continuent de craindre le pire pour les
personnes toujours portées disparus qui
se comptent par centaines
je viens de parler à mon concessionnaire
automobile ici il ne sait pas où est son
père il vit ici à altenberg dans un
immeuble et il ne sait pas du tout si
son père est vivant ni où il se trouve
parce qu'il ne répond pas au téléphone
on assiste à la disparition complète de
l'ensemble de la route
altenach on dirait qu'une bombe est
tombée comme pendant la guerre mondiale
en marge de sa rencontre avec joe biden
la chancelière allemande angela merkel a
exprimé son soutien aux familles des
victimes
je dois dire que mon empathie et mon
coeur vont à tous ceux qui dans cette
catastrophe ont perdu leurs proches ou
qui s'inquiètent encore du sort des
personnes encore disparues
j'inclus la belgique le luxembourg et
les pays bas qui ont également souffert
des inondations
une empathie partagée par le président
américain
ou encore son homologue russe vladimir
poutine dans la classe politique
allemande
les réactions se multiplient on estime
que ces intempéries tragiques sont à
imputer au réchauffement climatique
le thème de l'urgence climatique déjà
important dans la campagne pour la
succession d'angela merkel pourrait
peser encore davantage dans le débat
certains responsables politiques sont
pointés du doigt outre-rhin accusé de
récupération à des fins partisanes
un député écologiste a notamment effacé
un tweet qui attaquaient les autres
partis politiques à propos de la
question climatique des écologistes en
perte de vitesse dans les sondages
secoué notamment par des scandales
autour de leur candidate
anna lena bareback et en belgique à un
jour de deuil national a été décrété par
le premier ministre alexander de croo a
parlé des inondations les plus
catastrophiques que le pays ait connu
pour plus de précision on retrouve à
bruxelles raphaël blanc d'amour
bonsoir raphaël est ce que vous en savez
plus sur le bilan humain de ces
intempéries si en belgique
un bilan qui est difficile à chiffrer un
pour l'instant mais ce qu'on est sûr
c'est qu'il ya au moins une vingtaine de
personnes décédées est encore au moins
une vingtaine d'autres personnes portées
disparues dont on est sans nouvelles
donc le pilon pourrait malheureusement
s'alourdir
et ce malgré le travail des 500
secouristes qui ont été mobilisés sur
tout le pays et notamment des militaires
qui ont été réquisitionnés dès le début
dès les premières heures de la
catastrophe
et puis il ya eu aussi cette dizaine de
secours qui secouriste pardon venus
d'italie d'allemagne
et puis de france à vous prêter main
forte c'est plus sur les dégâts
matériels alors là aussi un fait est
incalculable
il y a littéralement des maisons qui se
sont effondrées effondré pardon à
certains endroits pour l'instant il ya
des communes qui n'ont toujours pas
d'eau potable
et puis il y à ces centaines ces
milliers de personnes qui n'ont toujours
pas d'électricité dans la province de
liège ont été nombreux à près de 17
mille foyers qui n'ont toujours pas
d'électricité
et puis il ya les infrastructures
ferroviaires qui ont été durement
touchées notamment sur des axes qui
reliait les principales wallonie où les
intempéries ou ont frappé très durement
et puis aussi sur des axes reliant vers
la capitale vers bruxelles alors tous
ces dégâts matériels il faudra des
semaines pour voir des mois peut-être
pour pouvoir les réparent être tellement
la catastrophe et est importante
merci beaucoup raphaël blanc d'amour
pour toutes ces précisions en direct de
bruxelles
c'est une première pour un ministre de
la justice en exercice eric dupond
moretti est mise en examen pour soupçon
de conflit d'intérêt il aurait profité
de sa fonction pour régler ses comptes
avec des magistrats avec lesquels il
était en conflit lorsqu'il était avocat
après l'annoncé de sa mise en examen le
premier ministre jean castex lui a
renouvelé sa confiance plus de précision
avec notre reporter katia technique eric
dupond moretti est mise en examen par
les magistrats de la cour de justice de
la république c'est dans le cadre de
l'information judiciaire ouverte à son
encontre pour prise illégale d'intérêts
les juges s'interroge sur plusieurs
enquêtes administratives qui ont été
diligentées par le garde des sceaux
visant des magistrats qui s'occupait de
dossiers le concernant
lorsqu'il était avocat alors eric
dupond-moretti at il cherché à régler
ses comptes avec des magistrats
notamment ceux du parquet national
financiers grâce à son statut de
ministre c'est en tout cas ce que pense
deux syndicats de magistrats et
l'association anticor qui ont porté
plainte contre lui
les juges devront éclaircir cette
question pour le moment
la ligne de défense des avocats du
ministre est clair selon eux le garde
des sceaux n'a fait que suivre des
procédures lancées par nicole belloubet
qui l'a précédée il n'a fait que suivre
l'avis des services m christophe ingrain
son conseil a fait savoir qu'il allait
contester cette mise en examen est qu'il
déposerait une requête en nullité on les
écoute
le ministre de la justice était convoqué
pour être mis en examen sans surprise il
a été mis en examen
il ne lui a pas été expliqué les raisons
pour lesquelles la commission
d'instruction a considéré que les
indices graves et concordants étaient
réunies et justifier sa mise en examen
ce mépris pour ces droits s'inscrit dans
la suite des anomalies que nous avons
constaté dénoncé depuis le début de la
procédure
eric dupond moretti a réagi pour le
ministre les syndicats ont mené des
manoeuvres politiques afin d'obtenir un
nouveau garde des sceaux
alors eric dupond-moretti va-t-il
démissionner juste après l'annoncé de sa
mise en examen
jean castex le premier ministre a
défendu le garde des sceaux lui
renouvelant toute sa confiance
hier emmanuel macron interrogées a
expliqué que le garde des sceaux avait
les mêmes droits que tous les
justiciables celui de la présomption
d'innocence et de pouvoir défendre les
droits qui sont les siens
donc pour le moment eric dupond moretti
est toujours appuyé par le gouvernement
en revanche dans l'opposition cette
annonce a fait l'effet d'une tornade
pour un ministre déjà contesté par les
féministes des sénateurs socialistes et
le secrétaire national de lv julien
bayou premier à réagir ont déjà appelé à
sa démission
depuis le début de la vème république la
liste des ministres et hauts
fonctionnaires qui se sont retrouvés
face à la justice est plutôt longue sous
la présidence d manueel macron plusieurs
membres des deux gouvernements dirigés
par edouard philippe ont démissionné en
raison de poursuites dont il faisait
l'objet d'autres sont toujours en poste
au sein de l'équipe menée par jean
castex qui sont ces personnalités
politiques et que leur reproche-t-on
on voit cela en images
[Musique]
ans
45000 euros d'amendé et un an
d'emprisonnement ce sont les sanctions
qu'encourent les professionnels en cas
d'absence de contrôle du pass annie
terre des sanctions que dénoncent les
restaurateurs déjà très touché par la
crise sanitaire il estime qu'il sera
difficile de contrôler leurs clients
mais certains d'entre eux sont déjà sous
coûts de fermeture administrative pour
non-respect des mesures de restrictions
sanitaires
estelle farge et grégoire douce et sont
allés à leur rencontre avec lui quatre
autres restaurateurs situés autour du
canal de l'ourcq ont écopé d'une
fermeture administrative de leur
établissement pour la patronne de ce bar
tout a commencé avec une première visite
des forces de l'ordre le soir de la fête
de la musique mon établissement est
fermé depuis
jeudi je crois depuis jeudi pour
fermeture administrative qui est arrivé
parce que nous avions soit disant pas
respecté toutes les règles pour empêcher
la prolifération du cabinda pour cette
restauratrice pas question de ne pas
respecter les règles sanitaires
mais selon elle aucune autorité ne lui
aurais donné d'avertissement est la
fermeture administrative serait donc
tombée comme une première sanction c'est
à dire qu'on est une mesure de peines
capitales avant d'avoir eu une âme ne
serait-ce qu'une amende
il se peut que de temps en temps on
n'est pas fait les choses correctement
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver on c'est
un métier très compliqué en plus pendant
la fête de la musique ça a pu arriver
c'est d'ailleurs c'est arriver à tout le
monde dans tout paris franchement ce que
les patrons d'établissements situés
autour du canal souhaite aujourd'hui
c'est de la communication est un réel
échange avec les autorités une réunion
était d'ailleurs organisée ce jeudi avec
la mairie du 19e arrondissement et des
représentants de la police dans le 11e
arrondissement cette fois rémy lui aussi
fait face à une fermeture administrative
la deuxième en moins d'un an fermé
depuis sept jours et pour une durée de
trois semaines
ils accusent encore le coup nous on est
peut-être au courant mais les clients ne
sont pas en quoi on fait de tout le
protocole sanitaire que nous nous en
pause on a en a pas non plus forcément
le le pouvoir de l'appliquer
mais comme il faut et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que la police quand ils
viennent c'est au lieu d'être dans la
pédagogie dans approche plus cordiales
ses dires est ça a été direct une
approche sous forme de pressions de
menaces selon la préfecture de police
depuis le début de l'année 420
établissements se sont vu sanctionné par
une fermeture administrative situation
sanitaire en espagne la catalogne
réactive le couvre-feu pour faire face à
l'augmentation alarmante du nombre de
contaminations dans la région il entre
en vigueur dès ce soir le point avec
clémentine laurent à barcelone plus
personne dans les rues de 1h à 6 heures
du matin et ce dès ce week end c'est le
retour du couvre feu en catalogne après
plus de deux mois où l'on pouvait sortir
librement le soir alors toute la région
n'est pas concerner seulement les
communes où le virus circule le plus
elles sont au nombre de 160 et une dont
barcelone et cette mesure tient pour
sept jours cela veut dire que dans une
semaine si par exemple à barcelone le de
l'incidence a assez baissé
eh bien on pourra lever le couvre-feu et
ce pour au moins une semaine
le feu vert a été donné par le tribunal
supérieur de justice de catalogne ce
vendredi
mais cela fait déjà plusieurs jours que
le gouvernement catalan demande le droit
de pouvoir appliquer un couvre feu et la
raison c'est bien sûr la situation
sanitaire qui se dégradent beaucoup en
catalogne je vous propose d'écouter la
déclaration de pennart à gonesse
le président de la région dans les
prochaines semaines
nous jouons gros pour freiner la
nouvelle vague de co vide qui menace la
catalogne au gouvernement nous assumons
notre responsabilité de veiller à tout
moment pour préserver la santé des
catalans nous assumons notre
responsabilité de veiller au bon
fonctionnement du système sanitaire et
éviter une situation qui peut provoquer
une aggravation de la crise sociale et
économique provoquée par le cos vite 19
comme l'expliquent le chef du
gouvernement catalan la raison de ce
couvre-feu vient c'est la situation
sanitaire en catalogne qui se dégrade
même si les chiffres ces derniers jours
sont plutôt encourageants et bien la
situation reste critique et les centres
sanitaires sont toujours débordé alors
face à l'augmentation des cas le
gouvernement catalan avait déjà pris des
mesures
ces derniers jours tout d'abord la
fermeture des boîtes de nuit et puis
ensuite la limitation des horaires
d'ouverture des bars et des restaurants
alors concrètement ici l'objectif du
couvre feu c'est de limiter les
rassemblements des jeunes dans les rues
et sur les plages la nuit car c'est par
ce moment là que les jeunes se
contaminent le plus il faut le rappeler
en catalogne ce sont les jeunes qui
tombent le plus malade du coït 19
l'âge moyen du catalan contaminés et de
28 ans et de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée la tunisie est toujours
dans une situation critique le nombre de
contaminations ne cesse d'augmenter et
fait face à un système de santé fragile
alors que le gouvernement tente
d'accélérer la campagne de vaccination
l'aide internationale continue d'arriver
sur place les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis bassem chebbi une
situation sanitaire a toujours
préoccupante en tunisie alors que la
campagne de vaccination s'accélère peu à
peu au rythme des dons internationaux
trente quatre mille cinq cent soixante
deux personnes ont été vaccinées durant
la seule journée du 15 juillet portant à
plus de deux millions deux cent mille le
nombre de tunisiens vacciner 11% reçu de
dos tandis que 5% seulement une première
dose sur près de 12 millions d'habitants
selon les autorités sanitaires
tunisiennes au moins dix sept mille
personnes ont perdu la vie depuis le
début de la pandémie
après l'appel a lancé par tunis et la
solidarité internationale se met en
marche l'algérie l'egypte le maroc ou
encore la france entre autres se sont
succédé ces derniers jours pour apporter
leur soutien au pays près de 3 millions
de doses de vaccins ont été livrés ces
72 dernières heures ainsi que plusieurs
hôpitaux de campagne
des unités de réanimation des
concentrateurs d'oxygène et différents
matériels médicaux en france le
secrétaire d'état chargé du tourisme des
français de l'étranger et de la
francophonie jean baptiste lemoyne a
indiqué ce jeudi que la france ferait
don à la tunisie d'un demi million de
doses du vaccin johnson & johnson
écouter on aura donné plus d'un million
de vaccins ensuite des concentrateurs
d'oxygène sont accordés à la tunisie
en tout depuis juin on sera plus de 85
tonnes d'équipements médicaux apportés
en solidarité à nos amis et à ce peuple
frère de tunisie la président de l'île
de france valérie pécresse a également
annoncé sur son compte twitter que sa
région va accorder une aide de 100 mille
euros à la maison de la tunisie pour
aider
l'équipement des hôpitaux tunisiens
écouter face à l'appel à l'aide de la
tunisie la région ile de france répondra
présente nous apporteront une aide de
100 mille euros à la maison de la
tunisie pour aider à l'équipement des
hôpitaux
pas question de laisser nos partenaires
tunisiens seul selon l' oms et la
tunisie enregistre actuellement le taux
de mortalité djoko vie 19 de plus élevés
dans le monde arabe
le bassin méditerranéen mais aussi
d'afrique je vous le disais en titre
l'indonésie est le nouvel épicentre de
la circulation du virus en asie il y a
eu plus de cinquante six mille nouveaux
cas hier en habitant sur quatre est
testé positif aux côtés de 19 les
hôpitaux sont submergés avec la
propagation du variant delta la
situation devient hors de contrôle
maxime abers des enterrements ce
sommaire et des fossoyeurs dépassé par
le nombre de corps
la situation en indonésie rappelle celle
de l'inde au printemps dernier le
ministère de la santé indonésien fait
état de cinquante six mille nouveaux cas
confirmés ce jeudi un record pour le
quatrième jour d'affilée les cas
quotidiens dépassent désormais ceux de
l'inde malgré un nombre de personnes
testées bien inférieur avec plus de
mille décès en 24 heures
le taux de mortalité est également
largement supérieur aux voisins du
continent comme les fossoyeurs sont trop
fatigués ils n'ont pas assez de
ressources pour creuser les habitants de
mon quartier ont décidé de les aider car
si nous ne le faisons pas nous devrons
patienter longtemps et intérêts au
milieu de la nuit une épidémie en grande
partie causée par le delta qui s'étend
désormais à java et bali les deux ils
obligés de mettre en place un
confinement partiel avec fermeture des
lieux de culte des centres commerciaux
ou encore des restaurants et une
circulation limitée entre les provinces
des mesures régionalisés mais rien de
drastique car le gouvernement redoute
l'impact sur l'économie
à cela s'ajoute un discours confus des
autorités et la minimisation des risques
sanitaires
la rapidité de la vaccination est super
importante même si l'efficacité a
diminué mais d'après notre expérience la
probabilité de décès des personnes qui
ont reçu une injection est très faible
face à la crise qui enfle jakarta promet
d'accélérer sa campagne de vaccination
problème l'archipel ne parvient pas à
trouver suffisamment de doses quatrième
pays le plus peuplé au monde l'indonésie
n'a pour l'instant vacciner que 15,9 de
ses 270 millions d'habitants à peine 6 %
de sa population avec 137 millions de
doses de sinovac
astrazeneca sinopharm et modern a en
stock
le gouvernement peut vacciner jusqu'à 69
millions de personnes alors que les
autorités s'étaient fixé un objectif de
180 millions de personnes inoculé d'ici
mars 2022
la lenteur de la campagne de vaccination
fait craindre le pire
selon certains médecins sur place si les
mesures sanitaires ne sont pas efficaces
le pays pourrait atteindre jusqu'à 400
milles contamination par jour le variant
delta qui fait des ravages partout dans
le monde en australie il contraint
l'état de victoria et notamment sa
capitale melbourne à un nouveau
confinement il est entré en vigueur
cette nuit pour cinq jours les 5
millions d'habitants de sydney sont
confinés depuis fin juin
oui c'est le confinement numéro 5 je
pense que nous vivons dans une dictature
comme le reste du monde
je pense que nous sommes le virus je ne
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de virus mais ça
fait trop tout est fait pour contrôler
les gens d'y être de choisir si vous
voulez vous faire vacciner et je ne suis
pas d'accord pour que les boks en soit
obligatoire je pense que nous devons
apprendre à vivre avec le virus et je
pense que c'est ce que nous ne faisons
pas ici tout sort en quelque sorte à ce
moment là nous nous contentons de réagir
en disant confinant cet endroit ce que
l'on ne comprend pas c'est l'impact sur
la santé mentale et sur les affaires
vous regardez la ville aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus personne ici c'est comme si
la ville était endormi et tout d'un coup
une faisons deux pas en avant et nous
faisons 15 pas en arrière donc la seule
façon de s'en sortir que je vois c'est
aller se faire vacciner et dès que nous
aurons le vaccin ils pourront commencer
à avancer la situation en afghanistan au
centre des discussions lors d'une
conférence qui réunit des pays d'asie
centrale et du sud en ouzbékistan parmi
les intervenants le président afghan à
achraf ragné le premier ministre
pakistanais imran khan mais aussi des
délégations américaine et européennes
ainsi que le chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov qui estime que la mission
américaine en afghanistan a été un échec
au chili les américains sont partis
comme l'a confirmé le président mbaye
donne parce qu'ils ont considéré que
leur mission avait été accomplie bien
sûr il a essayé de présenter cette
situation de façon très positive mais
tout le monde comprend que la mission a
échoué
on dit cela ouvertement y compris aux
états unis eux mêmes
le terrorisme n'a pas disparu des chez
certaines cellules d'al-qaïda ont
renforcé leurs positions en afghanistan
la production de drogue a atteint des
chiffres record et pour claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales situation en afghanistan
a imposé de mettre le sujet sur la table
lors de cette conférence conférence à
l'origine pour
occuper des questions de transport de la
logistique d'énergie de connectivité
entre les cinq pays d'asie centrale et
l'asie du sud avec la participation émis
des affaires étrangères des grands pays
concernés par ces problèmes et puis la
détérioration très rapide de la
situation en afghanistan que vous avez
démontré dans le sujet tout à l'heure à
fait que les ministres affaires
étrangères ont parlé de cette situation
de sécurité en afghanistan
le président de l'afghanistan lui-même
s'est invité le premier ministre
pakistanais également et par conséquent
on parle plus depuis hier que de cela
ses 20 ans de présence américaine
peuvent apparaître aujourd'hui comme un
échec mais l'arrivée des américains a
été causés par l'attentât des taches des
twin towers en septembre 2011 et à
l'époque moment de considérer que cette
intervention était justifiée d'ailleurs
aux nations unies il y avait un
consensus pour considérer que cette
intervention était justifiée calme
relatif en afrique du sud après au moins
117 morts dans des pièges d'une extrême
violence des incidents qui sont
intervenues après la détention de
l'ancien président jacob zuma mais qui
met en lumière la frustration et la
misère dans laquelle sont plongés les
habitants se sentant abandonnés par les
autorités certains décident de
s'organiser pour assurer leur propre
sécurité
rob actuelle les sud-africains
s'organise pour lutter contre les
émeutes et les pillages habitué au
désengagement de l'état sur les
questions de sécurité les civils compte
déjà sur les compagnies privées pour
assurer leur protection
aujourd'hui il semble passer à l'étape
supérieure en forme en eux mêmes des
collectifs de vigilance afin de
dissuader les pillards
la multiplication de ces groupe
lourdement armé fait craindre une
aggravation des violences marquées par
des tensions raciales selon certains
observateurs
mais pour les riverains c'est
patrouilles sont indispensables à la
protection des infrastructures
nécessaires à la survie des quartiers ce
n'est vraiment pas bon
notre centre commercial a été pillé et
ils brûlent en ce moment même en ce
moment nous protégeons ce complexe ici
cette chaîne alimentaire et nous
protégeons l'entrepôt et c'est le seul
endroit où l'on peut se procurer à
manger
nous continuons en tant que groupe et en
tant que communauté à nous occuper des
membres de la commune qui viennent ici
les troubles de ces derniers jours ont
mis en lumière l'insécurité qui frappe
l'afrique du sud sous équipés on manque
d'effectifs et réputé peu fiables les
forces de l'ordre ont rapidement été
dépassés par les émeutes et les pillages
dans les plus grandes villes du pays
face à la défaillance des autorités
le sentiment d'un bandeau est de plus en
plus important dans la population
je pense que le vice-ministre de la
défense ou quelqu'un d'autre a dit dans
une interwiew ce matin qu'il pensait que
les sociétés de sécurité privées à les
protéger les centres commerciaux mais
nous ne sommes que des citoyen sud
africains ordinaires qui espérons encore
que notre gouvernement va prendre soin
de nous pour faire face au déferlement
de violences le gouvernement a autorisé
le déploiement de plus de 5000 soldats
de l'armée sud africaine
le ministère de la défense espèrent
pouvoir mobiliser jusqu'à 25000
militaire pour ramener le calme dans le
pays
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain journal
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
des militaires français dans certains
essaient savait qu'il pourrait y avoir
des conséquences très graves sur la
population et pourtant ils ont mené les
essais nucléaires au moins lors d'un
essai l'essai centaure qui a eu lieu le
17 juillet 1974 l'ensemble de la
population polynésienne a été exposé
bien au delà de ce millisieverts cette
population là ne connaissait absolument
rien du nucléaire donc il a été très
facile pour l'état pendant des années de
nous vendre la thèse des essais propre
la ministre de la mémoire et des anciens
combattants geneviève darrieussecq à
elle dit que la france n'avait pas
commis de mensonges d'état qu'est ce
qu'on peut répondre à cela
c'est totalement totalement surréaliste
pour moi ce n'est pas un ministre de la
mémoire avec les ministres de
l'amnésique le président lui-même a
reconnu qu'il y avait eu ce nom